we got to go back to what you were
saying about barisma though because i
want to do uh um i want to uh
elaborate
and correct a little bit so you you had
mentioned that you know joe biden you
know he goes to the prosecutor and says
shut down the investigation into the
corruption of my son otherwise you're
not getting the billion dollars more
specifically it was that joe biden's son
for some reason was appointed to a board
member of a ukrainian energy company and
a lot of people wonder why that was the
case joe by a hunter biden's like look i
was an executive and i have experience
and i'm a lawyer and it's like sure okay
fine say whatever you want but the media
started saying there was no corruption
investigation into barisma it wasn't
into hunter biden it was into the
company and and uh michola slachewski
the guy who founded the company
that was a lie matt tybee did excellent
reporting on this breaking down how
there was at least a dozen
investigations and i'll tell you the the
kicker it's been a while since i covered
all this stuff because i was talking
about how i had to go to foreign media
to find the stuff out the media control
of the narrative is so pronounced that
they wouldn't actually do the basic
investigation into what joe biden did
and what joe biden did was criminal and
corrupt
based on what i've researched to put it
simply
joe biden comes in goes to the to the to
the head of you know the president of
ukraine and says either you fire the
prosecutor or you're not getting the
billion dollar loan he brags about it on
video
so they do
now the prosecutor uh victor shuken says
he was investigating corruption matt
tybee confirms there was an
investigation but i'll tell you that's
the funny thing is
after they get rid of the prosecutor
who's a so biden says we we uh got rid
of the prosecutor because he wasn't
doing the investigation
funny story after the prosecutor got
ousted zlatchevsky returned to ukraine
from exile got his money unfrozen when
donald trump comes in starts poking
around dude flees to monaco
tell me who is actually investigating
corruption
so i'll tell you this based on and it's
an older story but this is what the
media does
we see it over and over again with how
they frame things hunter biden story
when that came out the laptop and the
leaked details and we knew like okay
this this is legit it's confirmed what
happened big tech came in and shut the
whole thing back absolutely absolutely
then that's my whole point so
you know leading if people ask about the
the 2020 election and was it fair and
all this other stuff and i think there
are a lot of different layers to that
but
one of the reasons why
joe biden
uh is where he is today is because of
what you just said with regards to
censoring stories that were negative
about him and so we're seeing today you
know his poll numbers are falling for i
think a litany of reasons but you know
things are getting to a point whether
it's you know uh lackluster job growth i
mean the the the miss this last month
like i think what 725 000 jobs expected
225 000 added and then inflation which
is obviously we talked about this in the
last brutal and it primarily affects the
middle class and seniors on fixed
incomes be you know uh but also you're
looking at a wholesale collapse of
american foreign policy doctrine right
now you're seeing that most notably in
afghanistan
um but the things that are happening now
are almost impossible to censor and they
don't really fit into the media
narrative and that the way that you know
that the situation in afghanistan was as
bad as it was is because msnbc and cnn
were actually reporting on it so you
know if they're reporting on it it was
10 times worse than what it actually way
we're seeing it here well come on
let's face it msnbc and the left media
loves war when was when was the first
time they praised trump when he dropped
bombs on syria
that's when he became presidential
we talked about this before the new york
times and msnbc helped lie us into the
war in iraq in in 2002 2003
they have on meet the press there's
commercials for boeing
is the average meet the press person
watching meet the press in the market
for a 737 or is it a payoff of some sort
let's look i want to show you guys this
we'll talk about media manipulation a
lot of people like talking about how cnn
and msnbc all the ratings are in the
gutter they couldn't even break a
million their key demo viewership is
like eighty thousand to a hundred
thousand then i get people mentioning
being like oh tim you get way more views
and we're sitting here like man our
viewership in the key demo is way higher
than msnbc but it's not about msnbc it's
about how they're getting on social
media let me let me ask you know it's
really it's really interesting we're
talking about this manipulation stuff
how it is that someone like vosh who is
a 20 i think he's 26 he's a socialist
and he's pro-biden i'm like how does
that happen how does a young edgy
upstart socialist come to support the
crony capitalist corrupt candidate of
the establishment party
let me show you this thing on reddit
right here and we'll see if i can
actually you can sort of see the image
maybe i can um okay i can't get the
image this is r slash political humor
political humor they say it's got 1.429
million readers i go on reddit all the
time and when you're on reddit you'll
typically see these memes from political
humor now is it sane rational and honest
humor no it's manipulation how do i know
their image on political humor
is a man you can't really see it on the
camera sorry i can't show it to you guys
you can sort of see it there's a mother
a daughter and a son and they're all
looking at an open door as a man is
walking up the sidewalk to the house
like coming home from work
the family members are holding knives as
the dad is walking up coming home from
works wiping the sweat off his brow
on the man walking in it says joe biden
on the family members holding knives
hiding it says military industrial
complex and mainstream media
as if to imply the mainstream media and
the military industrial complex don't
like joe biden and are waiting to
surprise attack him
the narrative that you get when you go
on these big tech platforms these social
media platforms is that joe biden is
being unfairly smeared what what did we
hear recently i remember who said it
they were like the big difference
between joe biden and donald trump is
that biden doesn't have a main a media
apparatus willing to defend him at all
costs like trump did
gaslighting like who in their right mind
who remembered anything about this is
like yes the media loved trump they were
praising him non-stop
i remember biden being the worst
candidate in 2008 absolute most boring
like what is this old piece of trash
doing on stage why is he who is he first
of all and why is he up there he's
terrible annoying and then obama
appointed him i'm like what the heck the
worst choice on the stage and obama
stuck him in and now that nobody is
president how quickly people i mean if
you don't remember watching 2008 cnn
debates of biden being a just a but
old-school war hawk on stage i mean
disgust sorry tim what were you gonna
say no you're right you're right i don't
i don't want to drop you off you're
right how in ten years how much things
can change is just shocking to me but
what you need to understand is
the ten-year-old in 2008 was not
watching that debate
and they voted for biden this time
around
i didn't actually happen i missed his
1988 plagiarism debacle i don't know
where you guys do you guys vividly
remember where he
lifted whole parts of a uk labor
leader's life and assumed it as his own
is joe biden is joe is that his actual
name is he really named joe biden i
don't know his name is joe bob jr you
know that he i'm not kidding well i
don't know so he took he took
he took a uk
i was like how is it that i don't know
this shot so he plagiarized this guy in
1988 basically had to dip out of the
presidential election he had to resign
from the election process or whatever
and then
uh what people he stepped out of the
limelight for a decade people forgot who
he was and then he was still he was
still a senator he was like i never even
heard his name from night between 88 and
2006. did you guys yeah wasn't he the
guy who looked at clarence thomas and
accused him of being a rapist or
something like that i felt right i was
upset
joe biden said that he was number one in
his college class no he was like in the
bottom third i mean he lifted like as i
mentioned whole sections of some uk
labor day leaders life i mean yeah joe
biden has been like he has been a
fantastical liar his and now he says
he's like he's against the iraq war but
he voted for the iraq war i mean he's
just lies almost about if there was
something that he was lying oh oh about
going to um
uh the the the place in in western
pennsylvania the um
oh yeah i remember i can't remember the
name but i remember in squirrel hell
it's right in squirrel hill i can't was
it like a synagogue yeah it's a
synagogue my god the tree of life the
tree of life uh the tree of life he said
he was there he wasn't even there so he
just lies about everything but this is a
thing today when you have
you don't need a candidate when you have
the media
when they're all lining up to say
whatever they need to say and suppress
what needs to be suppressed as long as
you have that joe biden can call lid go
in his basement go to sleep that's what
he did is isn't it amazing that the i
love the atlantic article stay uh stay
alive joe biden all we need is your
corporeal form they just needed a name
you know why obama chose uh uh biden
some probably told him to apparently
what they were saying was that there was
concerns that voters would be worried
you know the first black president
wouldn't win so they said you take an
old white man and put him as the vp and
then racist americans would vote for it
that's that's a lot of the rhetoric i
remember hearing back in the day
so
is this at all surprising though i mean
you had what eight years ago somebody at
yale saying
what college was it they said there was
a clan meeting and it was like a white
sheet covering like a projector or
something like that okay oh yeah that's
right oh my gosh i forgot about it no no
it was like they looked through a window
yeah yeah and they saw like a sheet over
something and they said there was a clan
meeting and they were like turns out
someone just draped a sheet over a
project i forgot these people are insane
and then a
reality
reality show talk a reality show host
gets elected president and then a whole
country allows itself to be shut down
for a spicy flu
and there's still
people out there who
think that
it's killing
there are surveys taken all the time
that are like how many people have done
how many people do you think uh
percentage people do you think have died
in this area oh at least 20 percent
there's there's a poll that came out the
other day that said like 10
or something i don't know the numbers of
course you can get a corpse elected 10
of democrats believe that like something
like or wait no no 35 percent of
democrats believe that 10 percent like
the the 10 of people die with with kovac
so this is this is this is what happens
when you have people who blindly believe
whatever the media tells them and i'm
wondering what happened because i know
people who didn't used to they they used
to have critical thinking abilities
you know friends of mine
gone all of a sudden it's like they turn
on cnn and they're like joe roganate
livestock medicine they go wow
why would he do that critical idiot
critical thinking is critical thinking
in today's day and age is something that
is that is going by the wayside uh
pretty fast
liberalism was all about back in the day
in the in the wake of the vietnam war if
if the government told you to eat white
bread you were eating wheat bread didn't
matter liberalism was about tolerance it
was about free thinking it was about
critical thinking but the modern day
left has sort of shifted from
you know critical thinking
free tolerance to
almost a strict adherence to believing
everything that the government says even
when it contradicts it you see this in
reporters like you see this in reporters
and i learned this during my first uh
congressional run where
where we would be asking questions that
i think perfectly legitimate questions
about the election these questions were
important because
it should we should all aspire to make
our elections better every cycle and the
only way that you do that is by asking
important questions and and hope that we
can all work together to make things
better but what would happen is the
governor would release a statement in
response to us with no empirical
evidence backing it up and it would just
be like oh you guys are screwed up you
know what you're talking about and then
the media would regurgitate those very
same talking points so uh these are
conspiracy theorists so they're not even
they're not like
their job is to speak truth to power yet
what they do is just regurgitate talking
points from the authority thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you